as promised vice president formerly Joe
Biden now Wilmington Delaware
speaking about Co bid 19 that's why I
speak for others I like to thank those
who are already making sacrifices to
protect us whether that's self
quarantine to self quarantine themselves
or cancelling events or closing campuses
because whether or not you're effective
or know someone who is infected or have
been in contact with an infected person
this is going to require a national a
national response not just from our
elected leaders or our public health
officials but from all of us we must all
of us follow the guidelines of health
officials and take appropriate
protections to protect ourselves and and
critically to protect others especially
those who are most at risk for this
disease it's going to be making some
radical changes in our personal
behaviors more frequent and more
thorough hand washing staying home from
work of you're ill but also older into
deeply ingrained habits in our country
like handshakes and hugs avoiding large
public gatherings that's why earlier
this week on the recommendation of
officials
my campaign canceled election night
rallies we had planned to hold in
Cleveland Ohio
we're also reimagining the format for
large crowd events we had planned in
Chicago in Miami in the coming days and
will continue to assess and adjust how
we conduct our campaign as we move
forward and find new ways to share our
message of the public while putting
health and safety of American people
first above everything else yesterday we
announced a public health advisory
committee of experts who will continue
to counsel my campaign and be helped
guide our decisions on the steps to
minimize further risk and we also we
will lead by science World Health
Organization now has officially
officially declared koban 19
and Emin downplaying it feet overly
dismissive or spreading misinformation
is only going to hurt us and further
advantage the spread of the disease but
neither should we panic or fall back on
xenophobia labeling kovat 19 a foreign
virus does not displace accountability
for the misjudgments that have been
taken thus far by the trump
administration let me be crystal clear
the corona virus does not have a
political affiliation will infect
Republicans independents and Democrats
alike will not discriminate based on
national origin race gender or zip code
will touch people in positions of power
as well as the most vulnerable in our
society and it will not stop banning all
travel from Europe or any other part of
the world may slow it but as we've seen
it will not stop it and travel
restrictions based on favoritism and
politics rather than risk will be
counterproductive
this disease could impact every nation
and any person on the planet
we need a plan about how we're going to
aggressively manage here at home you
know you all do know the American people
have the capacity to meet this moment
we're gonna face this with the same
spirit that has guided us and through
previous crises and will come together
as a nation will look out for one
another
and do our part as citizens we have we
have to be we have to harness the
ingenuity of our scientist and the
resourcefulness of our people and we
have to help the world help the world to
drive coordinated global strategy not
shut ourselves off from the world
protecting the health and safety of
American people is the most important
job of any president and unfortunately
this virus lay bare the severe
shortcomings of the current
administration public fears are being
compounded by pervasive lack of trust in
this president
fueled by adversarial relationships with
the truth that it continues to have our
government's ability to respond
effectively has been undermined by
hollowing out our agencies and
disparagement of science and our ability
to drive of global response is
dramatically dramatically undercut by
the damage Trump has done to our
credibility and our relationships around
the world we have to get to work
immediately to dig ourselves out of this
hole and that's why today I'm reducing
the plan to combat and overcome the
corona virus the full details of the
plan to go want to see them go to Joe
Biden comm where I lay out the immediate
steps we have to take to deliver one
decisive Public Health response to curb
the spread of the disease and to provide
treatment those who need it and a
decisive economic response to deliver is
real relief to American workers families
and small businesses and protects the
economy as a whole our offered as a road
map not for what I will do as president
10 months from now but for the
leadership that I believe is needed
required at this very moment president
Trump is welcome to adopt all of it
today the core principle is simple
public health professionals must be the
ones making our public health decisions
and communicating with the American
people public health professionals it
would be a step toward reclaiming public
trust and confidence in the United
States government as well towards
stopping the fear and chaos that can
overtake communities faster than this
pandemic can overtake them and it's
critical to mounting an effective
national response that will save lives
protect our frontline health workers
slow the spread of the virus first
anyone anyone who needs to be tested
based on medical guidance should be
tested at no charge at no charge the
administration's failure
testing is colossal and it's a failure
of planning leadership and execution the
White House should measure and report
each day each and every day how many
tests have been ordered how many tests
have been completed and how many have
tested positive by next week the number
of tests should be in the millions not
the thousands we should make every
person in a nursing home available for
testing every Senior Center or
vulnerable population has to have easy
access to the tests and we should
establish hundreds of mobile testing
sites at least ten per state and
drive-through testing centers to speed
testing to protect the health of our
workers the CDC private labs
universities and manufacturers should be
working lockstep to get this done and
get it done correctly no effort should
be spared none no excuses should be made
tests should be available to all who
need them and the government the
government should stop at nothing to
make that happen
we must know the true extent of this
outbreak so we can map it trace it and
contain it nor should we hide the true
number of infections is hope of
protecting political interest or the
stock market the markets will respond
strong to strong steady and capable
leadership that addresses the root of
the problem not efforts to cover it up
secondly we need to surge our capacity
to both prevent and treat the corona
virus to prepare a hospital to deal with
an influx of those needing care as I've
been saying for weeks this means not
just getting out the testing kits and
processing them quickly but making sure
communities have the hospital beds
available the staff the medical supplies
the personal protective equipment
necessary to treat the patients the
president should order FEMA to prepare
of the capacity with local authorities
to establish temporary hospitals with
hundreds of beds
notice the department offense should be
planning now should have bent the plan
planning to prepare for the potential
deployment of the resources provided
medical facility capacity and logistic
support that only they can do and a week
from now a month from now we could need
an instant 500 red hospital to isolate
and treat patients in any city in this
country we can do that but we are not
ready yet and the clock is ticking as we
take these steps state federal local
authorities need to ensure that there's
accurate up-to-date information
available to every American citizen to
everyone so everyone can make an
informed decision about when to get
tested when to self quarantine when to
seek medical treatment and the federal
government should provide states and
municipalities with clear guidance but
when to trigger more aggressive
mitigation policies such as closing
schools third we need to accelerate the
development and treatment of a vaccine
science takes time and we'll still be
many months before we have a vaccine
that can be proven safe for public use
and produced in sufficient quantities to
make a difference but therapeutics can
and should come soon this will save
lives
when we want to put together and we pass
the cures Act of 2016 to accelerate work
on the National at the National
Institute of Health but now it has to be
made available make available resources
you speed up speed that process along
with the fast-track clinical trials of
the nine items while closely
coordinating with the FDA the Food and
Drug Administration on trial approvals
so that science is not hindered by the
bureaucracy and when and when a vaccine
is ready to go
it should also be made widely available
and again free of charge
we should also immediately restore the
White House NASA
security council director for global
health security and bio defense with a
full-time dedicated coordinator to
oversee our that response our
administration our last administration
we created that office to better respond
to future global threats after the Ebola
crisis of 2014 it was designed for
exactly this scenario but for some
reason I still don't understand
president Trump eliminate that at all
eliminate that office two years ago look
here's the bottom line we have to do
what's necessary to beat the challenge
beat this challenge sooner rather than
later we will beat it I assured if we
wait for it to worsen then scramble to
catch up the human and economic toll
will grow faster larger and more
dangerous Congress gave this
administration eight billion dollars
last week to fight the buyers we need to
know exactly what that money is going to
be useful how quickly it's going out the
door and exactly how it's being spent
this brings me to the second half of the
challenge in terms of economic
dislocation the coronavirus are gonna
cost in our country we must do whatever
it takes
spend whatever it takes to deliver for
our families and ensure the stability of
our economy taking immediate bold
measures to help Americans who are
hurting economically right this minute
it means we'll need bigger and broader
measures to shore up the economic demand
protect jobs keep credit flowing to our
job creators and make sure we have an
economic firepower we need to weather
the storm and get the people in this
economy back to full strength as soon as
possible this crisis good will hit
everyone but it will hit folks who live
paycheck to paycheck the hardest
including working people and seniors
another tax cut to Google from goal
when billionaires won't get the job done
another tax cut these folks will not get
the job done
indiscriminate corporate tax subsidies
won't effectively target those who
really need the help now we need to
place our focus on those who are
struggling just to get by people already
losing jobs we need to replace their
wages that includes workers in the gig
economy who lack unemployment insurance
parents are already struggling with
childcare costs we need to give them
relief children who rely on school
lunches we need to Bach provide food for
them
schools will need to help and ensuring
children who don't have a Kesey access
to computers can still learn if their
schools to shut down people have
difficulty paying their rent or mortgage
because they've been laid off or had
their hours cut back need to help them
to stay in their apartments in their
homes small businesses will be
devastated as customers stay at home and
events are canceling and we need to make
sure they have access to interest-free
loan up loans with interest
interest-free loans it's a national
disgrace that millions of our fellow
citizens don't have a single day of paid
sick leave a building need both a
permanent plan for paid sick leave and
an emergency plan for everyone who needs
it due to the outbreak now beyond these
national measures my plan also calls for
the creation of a state local emergency
fund to make sure governors mayors and
local leaders who are battling the
coronavirus on the ground as I speak
have the resources necessary to meet
this crisis head-on now these funds can
be used at the discretion of local
leaders or whatever they need most from
expanding critical health infrastructure
hire an additional health care and
emergency
personnel or cushioning the wider
economic blows this virus is going to
create in their communities we need
smart bold compassionate leadership
that's gonna help contain the crisis
reduce the hardship to our people and
help our economy rebound let me be very
clear unfortunately this will just be
the start we must prepare now to take
further decisive action including relief
that will be large and scale focused on
broader health and stability of our
economy look you can only protect for
the health of our economy we do
everything in our power to protect the
health of our people the last point I
want to make is this will never fully
solve this problem for unwilling to look
beyond our own borders and your gains
fooling with the recipe world disease
that starts any place on the planet can
get on a plane to any city on earth
within a few hours we have to confront
coronavirus everywhere we should be
leading a coordinated global response
just as we did to the Ebola crisis that
draws on the incredible capability of US
Agency for International Development and
our State Department Twista to assist
vulnerable nations in detecting and
treating them coronavirus were ever
expended we should be invested in
rebuilding and strengthening the global
health security agenda which we launched
during our administration specifically
to mobilize the world against the
threats of new infectious diseases look
it can be hard to see the concrete value
of this work when everything seems to be
going well in the world by cutting our
investment in global health this
administration has left us woefully
unprepared for the exact crisis we now
face no president can promise to prevent
future outbreaks but I can promise you
this
I'm present we will be better prepared
respond better and recover better we'll
lead with science listen to the experts
we'll heed their advice and we'll build
American leadership and rebuild it to
rally the world to meet a global threats
that we were unlikely to face again you
know and I'll always tell you the truth
this is a responsibility of a president
that's what is owed the American people
now the difficult days ahead I know that
this country will some of the spirit the
empathy the decency and the unity needed
because in times of crisis the American
people always always stand as one and
told the truth volunteers raised their
hands to help neighbors look out for
neighbors businesses take care of their
workers so we'll beat this challenge
together I'm confident of it we have to
move and move now thank you all for
taking the time to be here and God bless
our troops
like